good morning thank you for coming thank
you for joining us here I'm Howard
Mittman vice president and publisher of
Wired although I think that's been made
abundantly clear behind me welcome to
our annual event this is the fourth time
we've hosted the wire disruptive
business conference in conjunction with
MDC partners this is for those of you
who know me and those of you who've been
following my wired business conference
tweet bombs all morning know that this
is my absolute favorite day of the year
it's it's a data celebrate disruption to
write help people write a road map out
into where the world is going to bring
some of the greatest minds in the world
on stage and in the audience together to
learn from each other and I welcome you
all here thank you for coming thank you
for braving the rain and for making
today our fourth and largest ever
conference I hope that is especially an
experience for you as it traditionally
is for me today is about sparking
conversation it's about igniting a fire
it's about more than just the adjectives
that we threw up on screen it's about
really giving you a taste of the heart
and the soul of the wired brand and
that's really what what disruption is
about and it is the fuel that feeds us
it's the fire that burns and and serves
as a point of connectivity for
everything that we do here none of this
is possible without our partners and I'd
like to say a couple of special
acknowledgments to our Premium sponsors
American Airlines HP jacquet dro who I
urge you to put a business card out in
the lobby because they'll be giving away
a really magnificent and exquisite
timepiece to one very lucky guest ups
and Xerox will be providing notes on
each session and we'll be ready those
will be readily available throughout the
conference our exhibiting sponsors
Bombay Sapphire buddy media jive and
Ford SYNC powered by Microsoft and of
course I'd like to thank CNBC who's our
exclusive broadcast partner for the day
I'd also like to extend my gratitude to
my partner and friend Chris Anderson and
his entire team it is their their vision
their passion their commitment to
quality and excellence that makes
everything that we do here at wired and
I think for all of us on the on the
business side and for many friends and
fans within the wired community it is an
amazing thing to
to have the ability to tap into their
prescience intelligence and insight
every single day beyond that I'd like to
thank miles adult miles is a partner and
a friend he's also the chairman of MDC
partners he has been a consistent
presence here at the wired business
conference for the last three years and
MDC and all its agencies and shops
celebrate disruption in a way that's
very similar to our own they've been a
wonderful partner they've really helped
us out in a number of different ways not
not just sponsorship wise but really
ultimately with with helping us create a
look a feel and a vibe that that is very
much one that we want to identify with
so with that I urge you guys to tweet
post like you know Instagram I don't
even know what do you pick on Instagram
do all of it and please share this
disruption with your friends take it
back and use it and thank you again I'd
like to introduce miles in the doll have
a great day and come to the 4th annual
wired business disruption conference in
partnership with NBC partners this is
actually MDC some third partnership with
wired when I first met Chris Andersen in
July of 2009 it became very apparent to
me that was a brilliant hi na an
extraordinary thought we did together on
a conference told me about what he wired
this whole design dist I do
thinks outside box trying to reinvent
predicated on thought leadership
innovation owning growth for our clients
and reinventing brands and so when we
first got involved you know it was
overwhelming the quality of God kind of
thing various its trees in a very unique
way and if you think about what's true
quite extraordinary sting a subsection
of with this year's conference and
what's happened business-wise mark
around the world change we've actually
benefited in the in the world while
others have perished and I think this
year's conference more than anyone that
i have ever seen the quality of content
is extraordinary the kind of thought
leaders that chris and howard and their
teams have attracted is exceptional and
it's a variety of industries where
brilliant thought leaders are
successfully disrupting the industries
that they're involved with and driving
successful transformational change in a
way that I think is exceptional not only
in evolving industries but in maturing
industries and I think it'll be
fascinating to hear from everyone I'm
most excited to hear Marc Andreessen who
I only spend two minutes with in the
back room and he he's about other than
Bill Gates I've never been in the
presence of someone who int made me as
intellectually feel inferior and and I
think Alan Mulally will also be a
fascinating person because they're there
is someone who's reinventing a mature
industry that's had challenges etc
and there's so many other brilliant
speakers that we have today so i think
the content will be outstanding so on
behalf of MDC partners we're
appreciative and and and privileged that
our partners and our clients and our
friends are here together with us today
and our our fourth annual partnership
with wired will continue for many years
to come so I hope you enjoy the rest of
the conference I believe the content
will be as exciting as as it's meant to
be and I hope it brings you as much
value added leaving as we intend it to
be so thank you very much and have a
nice day take care